je ris de mars il annonce un miroir je
ris de me rhabiller en fac page
bonjour facteur
moselle futé a billion factor
vous allez très bal costumé à l'éval
j'en raffole
mais non je travaille je distribue le
courrier la maman bergen et blanc je
fais pas la distribution du courrier la
la la la mais si mes os pour quelques
dizaines de lettres par jour une seule
personne suffit à la la la la la la
aulas est retourné en juillet vous sur
moi venez vous asseoir
merci match au
sommet mais qu'est ce que nous disions
tout les deux eh bien je me demandais si
facteur était malade oh non non non pas
du tout non il est en vacances
la chaleur à ça vous pouvez lire
mes sous
j'ai soif excusez-moi aimez vous voulez
un verre de limonade au bien puisque
vous insistez lit ce sera avec plaisir
tenez voilà merci
elle est bien fraîche oh merci beaucoup
mais en fait j'ai une lettre pour vous
ah bon oui oui
voilà mademoiselle julie nerval un bon
maintenant je file à bientôt julie à
bientôt et demi
soit
il ya là dedans et demi comment tenez
vous bien je suis en train de réparer la
cage à poules casimir l'a complètement
détraqué en jaune d'or mais et demi mais
mais que faites vous habiller en feutre
je remplaçais mille îles est en vacances
oui aux données françois j'ai une lettre
pour vous merci merci mais comment s'est
passée cette première tournée autre
adresse
oui oui parce que je peux vous dire un
secret secret mais plus certainement je
vous écoute ton corps est la lay
line je vous écoute vous savez mes
demoiselles cunégonde tuner grand oui
celle qui à chignon way we alors est à
la botte et bien les jalousies le mourre
jalouse de vous et pourquoi pas ce
qu'elle aurait bien aimé remplacer les
pendant sa tournée assad lors de heurts
et vous savez des toujours derrière son
guichet d'impôts c'est vrai toute la
journée ont fermé la cour est alors
pourquoi tu es
m'exclus avril transformé transport vous
êtes là vous voyez
le chef du bureau de poste une a voulu
d'abord vous le savez pourquoi non mais
vous allez peut-être me le dire mais tu
dégonder bavarde harvard comme une pie
ix alors il a eu peur qu elle bavarde
d'une demi-heure par sin de layher par
là tout au long de la tournée c'est
évidemment un disque vous
jamais à moto jeudi j'ai fait ce qu'ils
font en mairie veut la preuve je vous ai
donné votre là tout s'est mis à rimer
mais c'est la preuve alors à bientôt
enfin au mas et disney
cette chaire est l'effet taille
asseyez-vous
futaie monsieur 19 août à vous avez tort
fait tailler plus gai enfin julie m'a
appris la nouvelle à la casquette
pouvait ravir cher ont bien c'est du
compliment oui ces dix là vous avez des
courriers pour moi ah non non vous
n'avez rien du tout
tant pis si je n'oserais pas mon monocle
on va mesurer ce que vous savez bien que
connaissent pas son monocle ou ses
lunettes en gardant au travers
décidément elle n'a aucun sens de
l'humour mais comme vaut le plaisir et
l'honneur de vos voix bon bien
simplement un petit bonjour comme ça en
passant oui je suis en avant dans ma
tournée je vais si vite
oh mais vous ne savez pas la meilleure
mais se disent non
c'est bien mademoiselle cunégonde savez
la demoiselle de la poste quelle chignon
et via les jalouses de moi noemi avait
pardonné moins chers amis je suis très
pressé j'ai un rendez vous urgent avec
une comtesse au revoir à bientôt
mademoiselle futaies et demi
mais que se passe-t-il mais pourquoi mon
oui si tu décides à une sacoche du
facteur un chef du bureau de poste m'a
nommé remplaçant du facteur qui partait
en vacances mais j'ai une lettre pour
vous si
[Musique]
vous avez déjà trois heures de retard
vous n'arrêtez pas de bavarder pendant
la tournée casimir jour en place bon
vrai mais mêlant fin mai mais je ne
comprends pas bien j'ai distribué tout
le courrier oui vous en êtes sûr de noël
critères et oui françois tonner mais
regardez
désolé
mais marion
tient casimir mademoiselle
[Musique]